jennifer is in Houston Texas hi Jennifer
how are you hi Dave hey what's up so I'm
calling because I'm ashamed of my debt
and I wanted to know if I should
postpone getting married or if I should
continue to get married but pause baby
step two to stack up money for the
wedding okay what is it going to cost
you to get them what's the wedding going
to cost so right now we're in the stages
we went ring shopping and the families
are involved so you haven't proposed yet
okay all right so but I have no money
and I have a lot of debt oh that's nice
you know how much debt do you have I
have about one hundred and forty eight
thousand dollars in debt you do them a
lot of debt are you a dog my boyfriend
it's in terms of how different we are he
would be like baby step four and I just
barely got out of baby steps line on
them so what are you a doctor or lawyer
once you're dead front yeah no I made a
lot of bad mistakes I don't have what no
no no no think that's what's the dead on
our marilee student loans a car and
personal loans credit cards or what do
you owe on your car my I have thirteen
thousand left and what you're delivering
again I have a bachelor's in economics
in an MBA okay so what are you doing how
much do you make I make about 71 I work
in IT right now good for you okay so
you're just coming out getting things
going and you know making 71 as a single
person you're going to tack this debt
very very aggressively and very quickly
okay
so you're working on getting out of debt
your boyfriend's already out of debt and
is your parents or his parents going to
help with the wedding cost or do you
have any idea I think it'd just be us I
know see the thing about is we talked
about marriage Boots how it would be
flea did overview about finances I know
he has a substantial amount saved up
himself so then he plans for the wedding
and you know for distance huh he pays
for the wedding then and you keep
getting out of that okay so he pays for
the wedding
should I before we do it should I pay
down some of this debt before I'm sorry
no you have a lot of that you have
enough for work on yourself
okay I mean listen that that's what the
the package that comes named jennifer
has a master's degree and a hundred and
forty-eight thousand dollars in debt and
all of the other things that are
wonderful about Jennifer the package
that comes with him is he is out of debt
and he has some money we don't know
exactly what yet I think you guys need
to really get into this and talk about
it but when you combine these two things
then you're gonna you know you're gonna
finish off the debt you're gonna spend a
limited amount on the wedding so that
you can use the rest of his money to
clear your debt when we are married
after we get home from the honeymoon I
understand you got some shame about your
past we all do we all do you could do it
over wouldn't you do it different oh my
gosh
don't let that hold you back kiddo you
got plenty of good stuff ahead of you
this is the Dave Ramsey show